when when we realized that the  determination of sex and gender in  humans is controlled by issues like the  X and Y chromosomes and that in some  societies people actively decide on  whether they want sons and daughters we  could change the models that told us  about the evolution of sex and gender to  include the cultural transmission of  preferences for sons and daughters and  that led us to ask some data questions  about how that preferences manifested  how it's related to marriage customs and  what the long-term demographic  consequences would be and that led to a  whole series of mathematical  quantitative models for the evolution of  the sex ratio and we in particular  applied it to the Chinese population